hey guys it is friday which means i have
this week's biggest stories all ready to
go to you here's what mattered rocket
League is getting a new playlist called
rocket labs where you can try out
prototype maps these arena layouts will
be available through the new playlist
after which player feedback will
determine which of them have final
artwork assets applied to them the first
levels available to players include a
utopia retro which is a circular map
underpass which features varied
elevations and double goal which has as
you'd expect two goals per team these
new maps won't be immediately available
in competitive playlist but much like
wasteland and snow day maps they may
eventually migrate over Mirror's Edge
fans has something to be excited about
this week as EA and dice announced both
a closed beta and a new trailer they
didn't drop a whole lot of details but
what we do know is you can sign up for
the closed beta on the mirror's edge
website for a chance to get in the beta
is set to arrive on playstation 4 xbox
one and on pc via origin no word yet on
when the beta will take place or what
content will be in it Mirror's Edge
catalyst is due out on May twenty-fourth
and then what is my favorite story of
the week and eight-year-old boy has sent
a letter to Nintendo apologizing for
getting his Nintendo 3ds wet the kid got
real unlucky with a loose thermos kappa
+ electronics situation in his bag which
resulted in the 3d are suffering water
damage as reported by Kotaku a twitter
user suggested the little guy should
contact Nintendo to get it fixed after
getting it repaired the Japanese boy
wrote a letter to the publisher
apologizing for the thermos incident
explaining from here on out I aim to
close my thermoses live correctly I am
truly sorry Nintendo are yet to respond
officially but we think they'd be cool
with it Bungie is pulling the desperate
ex-girlfriend act this week and asking
why you stopped playing destiny when all
they did was love you okay so not so
much that last part but they have
reportedly been surveying lapsed players
asking where they've been lately and
they haven't called some of the response
options available for the question why
haven't you been playing destiny lately
include a lack of time no one to play
with too much repetition and grinding
and new game came out that I'd rather
play a second question asks how likely
you are to play destiny again in the
future Amber's a space to leave comments
for Bungie where you can presumably
write things like new phone who dis
finally a new world war two shooters on
the horizon and you guys seem pretty
keen for it UK studio bulkhead
interactive are currently working on
kick-starting battalion 1944 which
they've said is an infantry based
first-person shooter with an emphasis on
war skill the game will also feature a
global competition system called a
battle rank as well as dedicated servers
and anti cheat measures to keep the
playing field fair bulkhead or after
100,000 pounds to make the game the last
major military shooter set in world war
two was 2008 call of duty world at war
let me know down in that comment section
what you cared about this week and if
it's relevant like you're not playing
destiny anymore just make on site I tell
you about the hardest puzzles in gaming
on the gist we show off our mode of the
week for Fallout 4 and we take an early
look at unravel those are all the good
things I have for you this week as
always let me know what matter to you
and I'll catch you again on Monday